[Music]
now as you know over 80 million of you
understand that i love heat but what
happens when you get the heat of the hot
ones
and mix it with some vegan ingredients a
dish that goes bang that's right i want
to show you a delicious vegan dish bang
bang cauliflower now oscar zoom in
please because we've got cauliflower
broken down into what we call florets
these little flowers with the stalk
rice
limes bok choy chili ginger
dried chilies onions a little bit of
cilantro or coriander depending where
you are the secret of this dish
is delicious and it's going to turn you
vegan in nine minutes and 59 seconds
let's have 10 minutes on the clock
please right we'll shallow fry the
cauliflower
pan nice and clean
hot pan for the bang bang sauce okay get
that up
to temperature don't put any oil in
there yet i don't want to burn the oil
okay a flower hold the cauliflower down
lift your knife up and just go around
the stalk and what happens
look these little florets come off okay
and they're like these beautiful little
flowers
and the stalks don't throw away great
for soups
now once you've got all these wonderful
florets okay lightly season them don't
worry if they break up a little bit but
it's just so flavoursome and that's
where the idea of this sort of dish
comes from i started making this with
chicken bang bang chicken bang bang pork
but with cauliflower so tasty in here
i've got some rice flour
salt
some pepper
no chilli in there yet just a nice dust
of salt and a nice dusting of pepper in
there in go your florets okay and what
we want to do now is just mix up those
florets the rice flour gives it that
really nice sort of coating and it helps
get the cauliflower really nice and
crispy okay so just dredge the
cauliflower in there for a little bit
okay now i'm gonna use sesame oil
and olive oil
okay and it's almost like a sort of it's
gonna be like a shallow fry not deep
fried there's a big difference
sesame oil in
and then some olive oil in okay
and just bring that up to temp
don't go crazy on the temperature
if it becomes too hot move the pan over
and just let it cool down
okay now watch what happens when i drop
these in we get this really nice crispy
shell in
okay
bearing in mind every time you go into
that pan
you're bringing the temperature down so
be careful okay
use the heat accordingly
now roll that around flood the pan with
too much in there you turn the
cauliflower really soggy okay so be
smart
now gauge the heat look at the color
listen to the noise
turn the heat up a little bit because
the cauliflower has brought the
temperature oil down now
for that bang bang sauce
okay i'm going to start off with some
beautiful fresh ginger
and onion you'll sweat that off first to
slice the onion in half
take off the root
and then literally get some texture in
that sauce
down
and slice
in pans on
we don't need to color the onion we need
to sort of melt the onion okay
so
in
olive oil in just a touch we want to
melt this okay
up with the gas
and onion in
from there
want some freshness
beautiful ginger give that a nice little
saute
pan down please oscar
look what's happening to that beautiful
rice flour starting to coat it's like
this nice little blanket that gets
crispy on the outside
touch of salt
in this bang bang sauce fresh ginger
just slice it down i like it quite
chunky because i wanna i wanna i wanna
feel that flavor i want to sort of
almost
you know get excited about the freshness
when you crunch that ginger you know in
your teeth it sort of it lifts up your
teeth and it's like the
sort of the perfect cleanser because it
makes your breath fresh and
it is so fragrant
fresh ginger in
chopped almost like little battens
ginger goes in
now
i'm going to start with the heat okay in
goes the chili
look at my cauliflower two pans rolling
now
this is the difference between shallow
frying and deep frying okay i'm keeping
the heat in the pan
i'm keeping these little floats of
cauliflower nice and sort of separate so
they don't stick together but look at
the color of them
sauce is working beautifully what we're
doing now is melting down that onion
and
that beautiful ginger
from there this is where it starts to go
up a level
a little bit of a
hot sauce in
next
a little touch of garlic don't go crazy
in the garlic
slice
little blades in
and flake that over i want the sort of
sweetness but not caramelized
once that hot sauce starts taking place
after that a little bit of sweet chili
sauce in there
now look what's happened to that sauce
and then
my maple syrup
and that starts to come together by this
rich
bang bang
beautiful sauce
now
turn that gas off
and let that sit there but
get your lime
roll that round
and just hit that bang bang sauce with
some fresh lime
that's going to lift that together
onions are melting the garlic is
apparent and that ginger is giving it
that nice fragrance
now
cauliflower look i've got the color on
the cauliflower
how do i make that just
a little bit more vibrant i'm loving the
color okay
it needs something green
so i just take a beautiful bok choy
i've cleaned it under the water i go
through the top once
through the side once and then back to
the top again scrunch it up
and look all i'm doing now
we call it like a little sort of
chiffonade and it's just thin nice
slices of bok choy
and that gives it a little bit of
freshness
across that cauliflower stalks as well
nice in open that up
i'm going to drop that
in
to my cauliflower
okay
give that a nice toss
now
i love it quite hot you saw in the hot
ones i can take
a lot of heat now get your chili
seeds in
but i want this to be sort of almost
like a raw chili because it goes in at
the end
okay chilli in
and now look you can see
while there's hardly any
oil in there
we've now got that collar on that
cauliflower everything is so vibrant
and then literally gas off sauce is set
and i'm going to just finish this now
with my lime
and then look
hit that
that smells
incredible look at the colour
that comes out
look
you can see how that cauliflower is
toasted
and when i say toasted i mean it's sort
of
shallow fried but crispy
that bok choy
gives it the lift
and the chili
is thrown in literally second before it
comes out
and that bak choy
[Music]
brings it together before i serve
i get my sauce i'm just going to
literally
drizzle that around
i like to go on the outside so don't
make all the center soggy
and then finally
coriander
sliced once and i mean once because i'm
just going to drop it
over
that there honestly
after 30 years of cooking
makes me want to turn vegan
for a minute
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsay and
ten cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're gonna come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck